what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host lis
today we are featuring angelo delos is
that correct
yeah d lulu but close enough
nice bro the lulu
yeah
is that italian
yeah it is
the lulu
you got it
angelo so good to meet you bro
nice to meet you
i'm excited for this episode simply
alwaysawake.com
so simple
three words
there's like this
simultaneity of their
always being awake and yet also the
appearance of falling asleep and then
wake me up
do you feel similarly
yeah well
when i uh use the phrase or the
terminology simply always awake it's
it's pointing to
something that is
actually in all of our experience
uh all the time
but our minds tend to
uh sort of
simulate i guess to use your terminology
uh
a structured reality
uh that sort of overlays this part of
ourselves that we all know intuitively
that is truly always awake always at
peace always at rest
excuse me um and
the pointing really is that there's a
possibility to
to sort of wake up to that or wake up
from the dream that there is separation
in our environment and our experience
and
very real shifts can and do happen
uh experiential shifts in the way we
perceive reality perceive ourselves
perceive the world
and perceive boundaries and so that's
really what the website and the book are
are addressing
so cool
so then there's the website and then
there's also the book which is uh linked
in the bible also awake
it's your turn
a guide to awakening
and
[Music]
that definitely also uh covers what you
just shared a moment ago which is
it's
basically a game of feeling separation
or not
and then
what what is your how
for when people
say i'm feeling separation like what do
you point them to
well
before the how
there has to be the what
and what i mean by that is
it's very easy to talk about subjects
like this or this subject or
spirituality or
transformation and identity and so forth
and for it to remain completely
conceptual
which is fine
um but the first
barrier the first boundary
that um
one has to cross before they really
intuit what this is about
is
to see through that illusion
that what we take ourselves to be in a
mental way the mental constructs the
beliefs the
sense of my past my life uh story
all of that
while it has its place is not deeply
true but most importantly it's not
deeply satisfying
so often the first
pointer that something
could potentially shift is suffering
actually is a feeling of dissatisfaction
unsatisfactoriness something just
uncomfortable in life
so excuse me this is just allergies uh
so
well
some people do sort of
start to investigate this this path
through just general curiosity and so
forth
many people if not most
the first real step
to authenticity is to start to recognize
that we
do have a sort of
uh suffering that goes on underneath our
layers of identity that keep us
in this place of feeling safe and
feeling oriented and so forth um
and without that initial recognition
that sense that there's something more
or something beyond uh that is
non-conceptual uh then the how doesn't
really get you very far it's it's it's
really a matter of
uh recognition first sort of thing so um
that's why i orient the book the way i
do the whole first chapter is kind of
pointing to this and trying to give the
reader a sense of what i'm talking about
and
it will either be
typically the reader either picks up a
sense of oh i know exactly what this is
i know exactly what this book is
pointing to and it's been there my whole
life and i've wanted to address it or
it'll be something like
no like this is not interesting to me uh
or even kind of scary like
i don't want to open that door sort of
thing so i really tried in the first
chapter to
use certain kind of language nuanced
communication to
help anyone reading get a sense of what
it is we're actually pointing to and if
you get that sense or once you get that
sense then we can start talking about
the houzz
sweet so then what would you say you're
pointing to and then we can go to the
house
um
you remember you told me to tell you if
you freeze
your visual has frozen
okay is it let me know if it comes back
yeah
at least on my end it is i see my face
moving but yours is just frozen that's
weird on my end it's showing up in high
res
and we felt like this might this might
happen but i'm good now
okay
all right let me know let me know if
that happens again but yeah keep going
okay
yeah you're you're a little you're
slightly choppy but now you're moving
and i can see your face and everything
so it's not frozen okay
um
sorry what was the last question
let's do the what the pointing is to
right first and then we'll do that
yeah
yeah well uh um again the the trick with
this so the tricky part with this is
when we talk about
what i'm pointing to with language
language definitely has
er has
limitations
um i've learned to speak
about this that i point to
in clever ways using language or using
pointings and so forth but
ultimately
um
language will kind of get you to
to a certain a certain edge
and you kind of have to step over that
edge
so i can point to it in various ways but
the you have to sort of take that
intuition and move beyond where your
mind gets you because this is beyond
concepts
because the the sort of simulation so to
speak is made out of concepts it's made
out of the mental sense of past
present well really even present but
past and future like a timeline and it's
made out of separation the sense of
being a self here and a body and the
world being out there so those sense the
sense of separation in space and time
is the overlay and it's cognitive in
nature so it has um
um
a certain um
a certain fixed structure that feels
enclosed that feels
um
uh
again unsatisfactory and so
the the key to this that i'm pointing to
is to feel to feel your way just beyond
that to to recognize oh there actually
is something here in my experience right
now
that is
not bound by my
mental
overlay of self another subject and
object
of
distance of there being separate objects
in my environment that i'm apart from
and i have to navigate all those objects
and people and situations to try to make
my life better and it's kind of like a
struggle all the time
that
all of that
is
created by the movement of mind by
cognitive processes and the the ability
to sense just beyond that is kind of the
first step but the first step is to say
okay yes i can see
how all of the ways my mind puts
together
time and space etc i don't actually find
in this immediate environment for
instance
very specifically past and future you
can imagine the past all day long but it
doesn't suddenly cause the past to
appear in your present right
so we can imagine past events past
conversations etc we never actually
change the fact that whatever's here
right now is what's here we didn't bring
the past into the present yeah so it's a
mental construct clearly and yet we
spend a lot of our time contemplating
that
similarly the future we imagine the
future we imagine a future conversation
even mundane things right what's going
to happen five minutes from now or in
the next room i walk into we're kind of
living in that world of the future well
what happens when we
realize oh that's actually not happening
either we're suddenly left in a sort of
um
um
un
filtered present
yeah i mean some some people refer to it
just as presence or as the now and so
forth but um
you can even sort of wake up from the
sense of there being a now
in reference to a past in the future
because that's still looking through a
mental construct when you see there's no
past and future there's really also no
now there's only what is and it's just
right here
um and so what it is i'm pointing to
what it is i'm uh describing
you could say is reality unfiltered by
mind which actually turns out looks very
different and it feels very different
than
the way we put things together with our
minds
not even purposely it's it's a
habituated experience and we all share
it collectively it's like the matrix
so when you
start to experience reality unfiltered
it actually feels quite different it
feels
much less structured much less solid
much less heavy it's it has a sort of
vastness to it it's also quite
paradoxical
because near and far stop making sense
in direct experience
past future present don't really make a
lot of sense
there's a there's a distinct sense of
intimacy of kind of like childlike
innocence uh that you almost remember
from childhood uh but it's not a memory
it's it's again it's instinct that is
suddenly sort of rediscovered and what's
so wild is that innocence and that that
um
intimacy of experience
uh is uncaused it's not like you find an
object and go well there's the there's
the intimacy like another person or a
relationship it's not like that it's
already here
and so it's paradoxical there's there's
a sort of emptiness to it in a sense
there's a when the simulation is not um
believed then what's behind the
simulation
is is almost like a lot of space and yet
there's there's a clear intimacy to it
and we're also far more um
attuned to the senses
sound and sensation but they they aren't
um momentary events they're they're
deeply immersive
uh experiences and these experiences
don't even have a subject object meaning
a person experiencing the sound it's
just sound hearing and it's
the loudest thing in the room it's it's
quite
again intimate is the word i use a lot
so that's what i'm really pointing to is
a a way to live uh without experiencing
the filters of mind
which are
pervasive actually in our experience for
most people
cool bro so
is
the filters that you describe would you
say that those are added on like onion
layers to
humans when they're born and that uh
there is the possibility of the like
baby uh never putting on those filters
uh i would say they are oh first of all
you froze again um so i should mention
that uh they are
yeah they are somewhat like layers
although
um
it's not usually until the layers have
come off that it becomes obvious
how those layers were constructed in a
sense it's not like you as you're
growing up you go okay i'm going to put
on the layer of self at
18 months old you start to actually
perceive the most fundamental sense of
self you don't decide okay i'm going to
put that on right because who would be
deciding that the most fundamental layer
of self is is just basic self awareness
like reflection in a mirror you know oh
that's me
um
and then a sense of
uh being able to perceive that other
people have internal experiences of a
self which is called theory of mind that
happens between three and four years old
so it's not like we choose to put the we
don't have the complex enough mind at
that point cognitively to actually know
we're doing it but physiologically it's
already happening so yeah they are like
onion layers in a sense and they do sort
of come off like layers but you're not
aware as you're as you're adding them on
growing up and developing itself and so
forth you're also not really aware even
as they're coming off you're aware
something's happening for sure but you
wouldn't be this articulate about it
until
deeper realization and and later on it
starts to become clear oh i see
because
what what you actually wake up to
is very hard to describe it's it's it's
there's a lot of subtlety to it it's
very obvious
um
it's more obvious actually than the than
the
more i guess more intuitively obvious
than the
the layers of mind and the cognitive
distortions that i would call
um
the the causes of this feeling of being
in a separate a world of separate enviro
uh objects and so forth this the
environment of separation um so the the
what you wake up to is actually more
subtle than that in a sense but it's
also more obvious it's more real it's
more real than real so
um because it's subtle because of its
subtlety it's actually quite hard to
talk about with language because
language doesn't really fit over this as
i described earlier
um so yeah it's really not until later
on uh after a lot of these layers have
come off that you start to really
get what happened and how how these
layers came off but you don't really
care it's not like you want to
understand it in fact you feel
free of the sense of having to
understand things all the time right
because if we want to understand things
often we want to understand so that we
can make ourselves feel better because
our identity is tied into concepts um
after
realization
understanding is is fine it's fun but
it's it does it's like our identity is
not on the line anymore we don't feel
like we have to understand to defend
ourselves or to feel better or anything
like that because
the
the the joy of just being alive is
uncaused it's not something we have to
learn about or understand and so forth
so um
so it is like layers of onion of an
onion but it's not always obvious as
it's occurring
so
very similarly to panjali back 2 000
years ago so you have yoga or union or
awakeness being just the cessation of
the fluctuations of mind so it sounds
like you're describing fluctuations of
mind being like the matrix being like uh
feeling a sense of self and then
connecting every sensation experience to
that localized sentence itself
is that right
yeah i would say that's a good way of
saying it and calming the the turmoil of
consciousness of the mind um
is part of it but what it really comes
down to is not just quieting the mind or
calming or stopping the mind because you
do that every night actually in deep
sleep the mind gets extremely quiet
there's there's no content but but you
don't just wake up enlightened right
like everybody doesn't wake up from deep
sleep enlightened so just stopping the
mind or turning off the mind or turning
calming down the
uh the fluctuations in consciousness in
and of itself
um doesn't necessarily wake you up but
it can be helpful so through meditation
through samadhi practices
calming consciousness while you're awake
knowingly calming consciousness and
remaining conscious can be extremely
helpful um
but
i would also add that i would
i i in my experience even more potent
sorts of um
practices are like inquiry inquiry
practice um
interacting with somebody who's gone
through this uh um that that can be very
helpful just the transmission of it uh
but yeah it is very much like that and
then the second part of what you said uh
yeah you're blurry now sorry i don't
know if you want to keep giving me keep
giving these reports but yeah i think i
think you you can keep giving me some
you've you've also gently froze a couple
of times a little bit but
um so maybe both of our internets are
not uh too spectacular right now we
could have possibly
we could also switch to zoom and just
record and then upload as another
possibility um i do like having uh going
live though um was this last bit okay in
terms of uh
audio and video
uh i i think so i mean i can't tell what
i look and sound like but um i'm just
like oh in terms of on my end on your
end you're still good
okay yeah i can hear you i can always
hear you it's just you're mostly your
image it changes
okay cool yeah i just want you i just
wanted to let you know
okay yeah yeah thank you yeah we can
keep letting each other know as as
needed throughout like when it does
happen uh okay
but sounds good
i think it is feeling good to to stream
but it's good to know moving forward
that when internet connection is
sometimes fluctuating um to
just record to zoom and then upload can
be better um so this last part was fine
though for me you can always hear me and
then the video was okay was that the
case um
okay cool
cool um they're saying the audio is fine
over here too so
oh in the chat yeah okay cool that's
good um that's good
okay cool yeah so and the second the
second part of what you asked um
i thought was really good and you had
asked um
or mentioned about he actually you might
have to remind me what it was now
well
yeah the first part was about quieting
the mind we were talking about so we
were talking about how that is great to
basically be able to do some inquiry
during daytime um just throughout the
days to always be acquiring um and to
just always be dissolving any sense of
self that's arising
um to not relate sensation experience to
a sense of self that's fantastic
um and then to be with somebody that
emanates this awakeness um also is
another great for transmission and what
not um sasanga basically in the triple
jump buddhism surrounding yourself with
other awake community
um and then i was injured in the how
also
but it might not be the exact uh right
time for it but it feels like it could
be
um but i i also really appreciated just
the depth of how you were explaining it
through all these different like facets
to the diamond of of a weakness um i
think that's really crucial
and
um
yeah i liked how we were talking earlier
about the um even onion layers building
up and how and then and then dissolving
and how you're not really aware of that
process until you're like 30 or whatever
and you're waking up and you can
actually you're actually quite realized
and you're quite convicted and you can
actually explain it then you kind of
realize that that was the process
happening
um but i would also like to talk more
about like the direct perception of what
you're referencing with awakeness and
what um
like if you feel that this is just it
talking to itself or reality talking to
itself it's not like a distorted um
sense of self
of atlas
angelo it could be the appearance of
that but really it's life talking to
itself or the one talking to itself
reality
so so is it somewhat like that for what
you would explain is like the awakeness
yeah i would i would say it is
really even simpler than that it's just
reality appearing
so there's not a sense of atlas and
angelo
uh at the root of experience
there's really just form and movement
shape sound sensations but even those
aren't distinct they're they're all it's
it's it's like synesthesia they're
they're
they they are sort of gateways or entry
points but beyond that it's really
unconditioned there's it's the
experience of the unconditioned or uh
sort of indeterminacy and and the funny
thing about indeterminacy is like the
mind does not is not interested in that
because it can't get a foothold anywhere
it's kind of like the cult the first con
in zen buddhism uh renzo zen at least is
mu typically what is mu you can't even
start to answer that question
cognitively but there is very much an
answer right um what is mu there's an
answer to that and it tends to be the
first awakening um
so it's similar to that and that there's
no way i can actually talk about what
this is exactly in one sense because
it's too close it's too simple too
obvious too close to um but also the
moment you say anything about it it's
already different
reality is constantly in flux it's just
there's
but again very paradoxically
the sum total of all fluctuations is
nothing at all so it's also not moving
so it's moving and unmoving at the same
time it's real and unreal at the same
time
this is very direct pointing and some
teachers sort of point this way
constantly it's it's like a
constant pointing from the absolute
which is okay but it can have some
downsides to it um it can blow some
people out it can be just too
uh too direct
and it can also
become
um
it can also become conceptual actually
like you can learn that instead of
actually realize it
so i try i i try not to fixate too much
in the relative or the absolute i try to
work with
a certain individual
in a moment-to-moment experience of what
they're experiencing as they're waking
up i try to sort of just feel into that
and work from where they are
nice so it's so the relative aspect is
really what matters with this because if
i'm honest i don't really have a
philosophical interest in it there's not
because philosophically there's nothing
to solve it's like if you if you live in
the ocean do you want to read a book
about how to find the ocean
you don't it doesn't matter right it's
not it doesn't make any sense at all uh
so but when someone wants to wake up
uh they have my attention when i feel
energetically or when i'm interacting
with somebody who is clearly suffering
and not only are they suffering but they
sense the root of the suffering is this
dream of separation and they really want
to wake up um
move their moves to wake up even if they
don't know what that means and often
they don't which is fine
that's that's when this engagement
starts that's when the
you can see the ball gets rolling so
it's very situational it's very based on
conditions so i don't walk around
talking about this subject like on a
day-to-day basis to people except in
this context which is now a day-to-day
for me but like when i'm at work or with
casual friends there's no reason to
bring it up um
so yeah
everything is conditions based uh
there's in buddhism there's the the uh
phraseology uh transient nature that at
some point you realize transient nature
is the nature of
of this it's unconditioned so anything
that you try to attach to that's
transient which is literally everything
you can describe talk about touch pick
up anything that feels like an object
separate distinct in time it's all
transient so anytime you attach to that
that's that's what causes suffering
ultimately to be completely free of any
attachment to
that which is transient which is again
anything you can pick up touch talk
about
uh describe
uh uh to be free of that is is real
freedom it's it's it's deeply peaceful
and the beauty of it it's flexible it's
it's peaceful in
generally any situation regardless of
conditions
um so so that's kind of how it tends to
flow it's it's
it's a in a certain sense it's kind of a
strange way to live um but
again in five minutes i'll have a
different impression and in ten minutes
there'll be another impression because
the reality constantly changes it's kind
of like a set of dice that keeps
throwing itself just recombining into
different types of realities different
types of expressions but when you don't
stand apart and try to make a mental
model of it constantly then you can
actually fully be swallowed up by it in
a sense are fully immersed into it and
then it
surprisingly is very enjoyable it's very
enjoyable to not know to not um
need to hold on to anything specific
to to just really enjoy the ride of
being alive
i love this
i'm gonna um
say goodbye to friends on facebook love
you guys we're only gonna be streaming
to youtube moving forward so just go to
uh youtube.com forward slash innovation
series you can keep watching there
okay so now it should be even better
now that we're only going to one
platform
um sweet
um
yeah so much good stuff there
um okay so i love the uh the totally
unconditioned
view
um
so
here you want to hear something really
bizarre about this
yeah it's not even a view
that in fact the almost the most
fundamental
aspect of the sense of separate self
is actually
what some something you might call an
inherent view
the tendency to form a view at all
it's so interesting and it can be
everyone's difference but for some
people can be very sticky this part can
be very sticky for them it can be really
challenging to let go of whereas
the word to nature right after i said it
oh yeah no no
it's not a criticism of you at all but i
just wanted to point that out that like
it is interesting that right at the
almost event horizon where beyond that
is really the unconditioned the the most
fundamental thing it's it's a very it's
not even an opinion it's not an opinion
type view it's it's a
energetic
yeah it's an energetic frame of
reference that the mind is still trying
to get to get its first foothold to
build the story to build out the
narrative and the sense of separation
um and
yeah over the horizon
that's almost like
that's a really important part um
to
the
uh to the non-being or the non-existence
or the the emptiness or the nirvana on
the other side
the initial formation of any type of
viewer any type of perception or any
type of idea or concept or
any like or dislike craving attachment
whatever just from right yeah from right
there into the beingness into the
existence-ness
is then all of the different
awesome sorry stuff
uh and so
cute like to be able to like feel that
because it is really like an event
horizon more than anything i love that
you said that
yeah well said
also as you're mentioning all of that i
thought to say this this may be helpful
for anyone listening but
the unconditioned that we're talking
about it's not a thing it's it's all of
this but um
it you're right that has no has no
preference it has no
specific frame of reference or
referencing isn't something it it's
concerned with um it and there's
certainly no separation boundaries
anything like that and that's that's
literally right here right
um
for everyone actually so
uh
the but the thing i want to add to that
is our mind will get a hold of that
sometimes hearing that and it'll think
i'm going to walk around
well let me say it this way it will it
will think that uh let's say a liberated
being a liberated person um would have
no preference
and
it can you can you can mistakenly
interpret that if you look at somebody
and say well
they're you know i don't know dalai lama
or adi shanti or i don't there are
people out there who are quite liberated
you can look at them and say well sure
they but they prefer food eating food to
eating poison right
or something like that like the body
mind doesn't lose intelligence
in that way
the key though the key is
at the level of identity
there's not identity tied into
um preferences
there's not identity tied into
relationality needing to relate all the
time to experiences and objects around
you and and navigating and negotiating
that constantly requires a ton of energy
when that that can actually completely
stop
and it stops ultimately it really stops
when identity stops when the sense of
identity as a construct itself subsides
when that happens everything changes but
you don't lose the ability even to look
at your own body and experience and go
well yeah i mean i i prefer eating i
don't know pizza to
horseradish or something like that you
can still reflect and see that the
tendencies can be there on a physical
level in a physiologic level in the
relative sense or you could say the
conventional sense
but there really is no identity behind
any of it and that makes all the
difference because it's very heavy it's
a sense of identity is far heavier than
we really
realize typically until it subsides and
then things get very light
yeah
so good
for sure identity is so at the core of
it it's so well said
yeah and either this is uh all
the one with itself
self capital s with itself however you
want to share that uh or it's no self in
the sense that there isn't a
a distinct separate uh sense of self
among us but there is only energy
dancing appearing playing with itself
blah blah
and so it's just it's really sweet and
it's really important like you said it's
the most important thing about
everything with awakeness
for one from what i've understood
is that it has to be like a felt
moment-to-moment um
vibration or frequency
um like that's just continued basically
above everything else so above
everything else there's like this
constant stream of inquiry you could say
that's just pervading
um
your existence above everything else is
just like this this sol this um
above like in the north star position is
just a constant stream of inquiry that
into the nature of self into the nature
of sensation uh into the nature of
reality that's just running in the
background you know frank a good friend
frank yang has called it like a
contemplative fitness ai that's just
running
yeah
yeah and i i love that way of expressing
it too and then even that to an extent
as it as as you've exhausted in a sense
all association is throughout the day
non-stop every day
uh it also subsides because all their
all that's left is just what is um yeah
and that's yeah
yeah what you're saying is is very true
it's clear i would i would like modify
it slightly just for because not because
what you said was wrong but just because
language is tricky and just to continue
the conversation that
that's exactly right inquiry if done
properly and i try to really describe it
in my chapter in the book um
well you can't really do it improperly
as long as your heart's in the right
place you're really curious about
reality what is self what is thought
what is anything right what is solidity
if you're really curious you really
can't really do it wrong but there are
some nuances that you can attune tune
into and and inquiry can become very
powerful um but
what i really try to do in that chapter
is attune people to inquiry in a way
that
when these self layers start to fall
away that's what's already happening
you'll you'll see that it is it's like
there's no one doing the inquiry but
there's an absolute fascination with
with reality just being fascinated with
itself coming into being out of
absolutely nothing all the time it's
crazy but it's doing
it it's it's just it's literally a
radical fascination but it's like also i
want to point out like it's not like the
inquiries in the background it is but
it's also in the foreground and there
and it's looking to see is there a
difference between a background and a
foreground and all of a sudden the
background and foreground are one and
the same so now what does space even
mean what does distance even mean right
it's like that's the kind it's going on
all the time
it's just this fascination with reality
being fascinated with itself and
never even happening at all nothing is
moving at all and that's she got time
emptiness you know unconditioned so um
frank's right on the money it's exactly
i i know i don't know him personally but
i've watched a couple of videos and he's
very he's right on it so um
it's uh
yeah i mean it really becomes
indescribable
nice and
another one that uh came up while you're
sharing was the
like the still flame or
um movement and not moving at all at the
same time
um
yeah and
just like the piece at the same time as
the exterior artistry
um
there's just uh there's a spontaneity or
like a bounciness that comes with the
artistry when it's like free um
yeah so it's not referencing like a self
image um all the time basically
um
the default mode you could say or the
mind mode or the matrix mode is to
always be filtering everything through a
sense of self-image
um
and then that at some point drives you
so crazy
with suffering
so then it's like the drill sergeant of
like [ __ ] waking up and then um
and then there's like just what feels
like slowly like this like just
dissolving of all attachment to
self-image
um
and then just like associating oneself
identity wise more and more with
nothing and everything at the same time
um and of course something also
um
and just covering all the bases and just
feeling like
really good that uh
to be like identity like to be so
entangled in no identity and something
and everything all at the same time
um and
um
and i yeah and i just i feel like that
that's at the core we're talking about
like last 20 minutes or so which is
great um
so we've been friends that are curious
like
um
you know when we were talking earlier
when i mentioned that
just even the calming down of the
fluctuations of mind like using the
breath as a tool is a really good how to
basically bring a steady
uh concentration or focus
to
your moment-to-moment experience of
sensations and sense of self
and then from there it becomes easier
and easier to liberate yourself from
self-image into this coalition
um
yeah yeah yeah you you mentioned um
um
man i lost it i'm with you right here so
everything you say it just disappears
but
um
okay with consciousness specifically uh
with calming calming the mind um
again you know meditation meditative
practice can be helpful following the
breath all these different things um but
i just want to point out for anyone
listening that um i
generally i do this different ways with
everyone everyone wakes up differently
but i generally
do emphasize
um
a first shift a first awakening it's
it's very zen-like this is very
branzizen-like actually and it tends to
be the people i work directly with it
tends to tends to happen that there's a
very very distinct and abrupt shift that
happens which is probably the biggest
shift you'll ever experience
um
as far as contrast is concerned and it's
the first big awakening ken show um and
it is
what it does actually is it's a it's a
if you can make the mind one pointed
enough through inquiry self inquiry can
work inquiry into the nature of thought
and who's the thinker
inquiry into the nature of consciousness
itself which is what the thought is
formed out of what the thought is made
out of what it subsides back into and
what it appears out of it's all
consciousness that's all that thought
that [ __ ]
so you can inquire into the nature of
that
so continuously that it just becomes
nothing but that or just a very
one-pointed approach by just boring into
something like mu what is mu something
that no concept can get a hold of and
yet you can just become more and more
and more one-pointed with moo until it's
just moo moo moo so how however you do
this
that you can get to this point where the
mind is so concentrated or conscious
there's such a one-pointed approach
inside consciousness that an actual
reset happens it really is a reset in
consciousness and it can be
tremendously a tremendous release for
people it's very life altering for many
people um for almost everyone really uh
but from then on it's actually much
easier to access this unbound
consciousness this ability to to remain
in consciousness uh with really no
content no thought content and then and
from there you realize pretty much all
the content of your life is thought
content right them everything is mind
every everything you can make into an
object of any kind at all it really is
made out of thought and this is how some
people with that first awakening start
to perceive everything is made out of
consciousness like there's no external
world with all consciousness out there
and that's a that's a reasonable
interpretation of that stage of
realization it does go beyond that for
sure but from that place it is so
freeing because you can just stop
and just experience yourself and
everything is consciousness that it
really can be with no content it's like
the big s the self with the big s you
know um and
so so yeah calming the mind meditative
practices all that's great but if you
really want to dig into this
then i often
sort of push people a little bit toward
that i say you know
develop a one-pointed approach or just
orient to the nature of thought itself
and really find out what's in there what
is consciousness what is what is the
sense of you as the thinker right now
that's never changed throughout your
life when you've been awake and yet the
thoughts change all the time what is
that is it apart from the thoughts that
kind of thing so i i really try to
orient people to that because after that
big reset in consciousness the first
awakening it's much easier much much
easier to address these further layers
the layers of separation the layers of
inherent view uh the layers of the
reactive self the relational self these
are all just
mechanisms of selfing
those are the layers that still feel
like self even when you know there's not
a self right there's still the things
that catch you and make you feel
contracted so it's much easier to
address it as a verb it's so funny yeah
i love it
as a verb yes selfie is so that's so
good yeah um yeah that it's an actual
like movement of of consciousness is uh
whether it's tied to a sense of self or
not or going through the process of
inquiring into that sense of self
um
it's actually a very small collection of
mental faculties it's really just a
handful of things that continue to
create a very seemingly solid sense of
self and yet if you just one by one you
you disassemble those or you inquire
into them deeply enough that you see
there's actually no self doing that
and with non duality specifically the
sense of there's not actual boundaries
like formlessness you're actually
inquiring into
then you're really inquiring into the
nature of of the relationship of thought
or mind
to the senses themselves that's
ultimately what it is but it's you know
it's like is there actually a boundary i
can look at an object and look at my
hand
how long does the how long does the
tension stay there
before it starts
popping back into mind to reference
something in thought meaning
narrative
labels about what i'm looking at
often the narratives are about the
practice like oh am i experiencing this
well so-and-so said that is it that wait
a minute that's all thought put your
attention right back there right that's
very very hard to do before awakening
it's it's surprisingly hard to do direct
and i call it direct experience so once
you have access to direct experience um
these these further layers are not that
hard to to
disassemble it takes some shadow work
often though really i mean you really
sometimes the stickiness that keeps
pulling you into mind is about certain
kinds of traumas or whatever your
vasanas are you know your collection of
baggage you need to work with and
sometimes you have to go back and do
that like really look through the
emotion body and find out what's going
on feel things that you've not been
feeling all your life and uh in a very
direct way that you might not want to
and then find the resistance patterns
and see what is resistance anyway what
is it even made out of energetically and
like these direct investigations so yeah
so good
i'm just checking out the comments over
here
hello everybody
everyone how are we uh still doing on uh
audio and video we still doing okay
um
let us know in the comments how it's how
it's going you've been great by the way
in terms of audio and video on my end uh
occasionally there's a little video
thing but uh otherwise it's good
and uh and me right now you can hear me
clearly okay the video is okay
uh your video freezes on occasion it'll
just freeze in a but it's always a nice
posture it's always a good look on your
face or something and then like a
contemplative look and then it starts
moving but your sound has been perfect
from my end cool good good okay
oh man
so
it's so good
um
okay i feel like it would be relevant to
um to play a bit on what you were just
sharing with
um
some like steps and stages and then um
some house along that so let's see if we
can do a little recap
so
um we have
like
we have a
we're we're very like drawn
to
uh the to what appears like the physical
world and we're very drawn and like
attached to that and all the objects and
all the the differences in the
separation
and we don't really even recognize that
there's like consciousness
that kind of everything is like
dependent on
and then and then we like so the first
sort of shift is like away from the
senses and away from the physical
objects and the separation and the
distinction to like okay well what is
the thing that is
conscious or sentient or aware of
everything and then then you get to oh
okay so
um
this has to be the ground like sentience
or consciousness has to be like some
sort of a ground and then
then then there's more of like an
impersonalization or a trans
personalization you could say of that
consciousness into like oh this is all
the same observer all the same
consciousness um which is infinite and
like it's
a universe is like what we are and we
like we made a universe to like to
explore and like uh
okay uh-huh so there's another stage and
then
and then i think then uh like which i
think a lot of people also end on that
as a ground which i think is a great uh
place also to to speak about realization
i think that's also a great place like
um
but then i think this next one is where
um i think is kind of like where the
athletes of consciousness like to go um
or the olympics of consciousness are
played which is where
um
there's an investigation
of the nature of self
on a moment-to-moment basis the nature
of experience and sensation and
self-image and the way that i i appear
and i try and extract something from
another self or i want to be seen in a
specific way so i say so i say specific
words to try and get something
um
to feel some sort of a lack belief that
i've had about myself since childhood
like you indicated it can be very
traumatic from being a kid as well
um
and so then there's like a much more of
a moment-to-moment inquiry into the
nature of sensation experience self and
liberating oneself more and more into
the unconditionality
um and i would say that that is then the
awakeness is that about a somewhat
similar way that you would share the
levels yes david
you actually summarized it really really
well i'll just add a little bit in as as
i go through that same model but as you
described
the first big shift is like wow i mean
you you just have this access to unbound
consciousness unbound being really
beingness of what you've taken yourself
to be all of a sudden that just expands
out to infinity and some people perceive
it as like a sense of pure sense of i am
not a thought of i am but the sense that
i am
is the most primary thing that can be
experienced and it's self-validating and
it's more real than anything you took to
be real before and that and and other
people it goes it's a little more it
goes a little bit more almost to what
you described as the trans-personal
where there is that sense of pure
consciousness but then there's like
something that's even almost more thin
going on and and that so that shift that
that
new place you find identity in a sense
let's say
or identity just dilates out into
infinity in a sense
that
is like waking it is like waking up from
the matrix really that first shift but
what i often say is
what comes after that is like
you're you actually wake up from one
matrix and you're kind of in another one
but it's a very different kind of matrix
it's it's far bigger it's far more
flexible it's like it's like the
matrix's safety mechanism to keep you in
in the big in the real matrix
because you wake up from one and that
can be also part of your story so
um so this really is that first shift
that first awakening really is the
beginning of the true spiritual
progression or spiritual in quotes if
you think of it this way but it's the
progression of realization it's it's the
first and very important shift stream
entry let's call it um
the the what's interesting is the way
you proceed beyond that
if you do it all and as you said a lot
of people
that's
i don't know if it's just based on
conditions and so forth or what it is i
feel often it's based on
something in the background
from the human level emotional things
and so forth that keep you not wanting
to look deeper in a way it's like a
little bit of fear still there is often
what keeps people there but but it's not
but it's common that people sort of stay
there for a long time after um so i
think we're changing things i think with
the like the internet with you know adi
shanti frank gang gangaji like you can
turn on
youtube and see enlightened beings and
and and
literally
vibe with them immediately on the video
you don't have to go meet them it's
amazing i think we're changing i think
people are starting to actually wake up
deeper
probably more
probably faster
and certainly in greater numbers i'm
almost positive of that and i've talked
to many people have been in this sort of
teaching thing for a lot longer than i
have
um and they they tend to agree
but
but yeah the the way you approach
realization beyond that first
realization before before that first
awakening
uh is just different and it's different
and you have to kind of look at it in
different ways um you have to look for
subtle things but but on the other side
of things you have to do the personal
work you have to do shadow work at some
level you just have to because that's
the easiest way to not wake up further
is is to like just not see something in
yourself to convince yourself you're
enlightened you know and then go
convince other people you're enlightened
which can get into some really weird
stuff so
um so yeah the the ways that you
investigate
identity beyond uh consciousness are
reasonably subtle
somewhat specific
um and require a modicum of humility uh
willingness to be vulnerable to feel and
see and
mostly feel things you haven't wanted to
feel and you've built identities to
avoid feeling we all do it
everyone's done it
and so so you've got to kind of look at
different places you can't just meditate
yourself into enlightenment like after
that by trying to have nervy culpa
samadhi 24 7. like that's not the answer
any from from here on it's it's part of
the answer meditation is great and you
you should keep doing it and keep
inquiring but it's important to inquire
in certain places and
this is where i i put this very early in
the book but this piece of advice if i
could give one one piece of advice for
the whole spiritual journey
there's probably a handful but one i
think that's probably the most important
or at the top is be willing to be
uncomfortable like don't convince
yourself that this whole process is
gonna be nothing but bliss and
and peace and mind expanding cosmic
experiences you're gonna probably have
those but that's not all you're going to
have just trust me on this
um people i work with that are very very
sincere about this and wake up and it's
their priority in life they wake up to
very
deep and nuanced stages of realization
they go through a lot and and but
they're willing to do it you know and
we're all you know there are there are
days when i don't want to do it you
won't want to do it and whatever but
there are you have to have some
commitment willingness to go through
the root of suffering right you have to
you have to get to the root of it you
have to find out what it's about and oh
this is one thing i want to address that
you mentioned before with the suffering
is what sort of prompts us in the first
place but it really turns out that
suffering is grace right without that
suffering without that huge doubt mass
without feeling like a prisoner in my
own mind from the time i was i don't
know like 10 to 24 years old i don't
know if i would have done this it takes
a lot to actually break through these
barriers uh a lot of surrender a lot of
willingness to let go so um so in
retrospect suffering really is grace
um
if you don't you know if you don't go
completely unconscious and use it to
perpetuate violence or something
but it's the raw fuel of awakening for
sure so be willing to to feel everything
that's you're going to have to feel
you're going to feel things you don't
want to feel every single person who
goes through this will feel things they
don't want to feel by definition because
again identity is actually structured to
avoid pain
to avoid things we don't want to see but
when that pain is
a result of identity then we have to
actually go into it we have to see it
clearly for identity to disentangle
itself so we can truly know what freedom
is nice i remember andrew houston also
on our show said that the suffering or
the pain or the fear always
um are the divine fuel
so if there's like a new relationship
that we make like you're suggesting to
um the nature of sensation and
experience where we're recognizing it as
a uh as a school or for the one for
itself um
and that style approach
is
um to see it as divine fuel
to like
to just feel that as divine fuel it just
changes everything um
and i i love that but so that would be
your one big like takeaway is to like
tune into how everything that arises is
like divine fuel for the one to wake up
to itself
yep another way of saying that is
there's a lot of talk of presence now
right in pop culture and uh wellness
culture and awakening all of it presence
right and
and everyone knows what presence is at
some level of course uh but what i often
will point out to people is like
presence can be
blissful peaceful
contentless um
intimate it's wonderful right but it can
also be
sadness
sadness is present like when there's
sadness
that's presence presence is expressing
as sadness or
anger or frustration like all of those
experiences
are truly buddha nature right everything
ultimately is awake nature it is uh so
that doesn't exclude anything so when
you find something comes up from your
unconscious and it's like oh my god
there's shame i'm feeling shame feel it
feel it don't deny it don't pretend it's
not there don't tell yourself i'm too
awake for that it's that's nonsense it's
it's an experience every experience is
allowed reality doesn't filter
experiences it doesn't have a problem
with any experience it's it's perfectly
okay everything is perfectly okay here
um and uh
that kind of willingness you know that
that is probably i don't know if it's my
number one my number one advice honestly
my number one piece of advice is
trust that there is that there is that
there's a way out of suffering really
like if you're suffering
and some something some glimmer inside
you picks up this message we're talking
about
and and says yes i know that like i've
heard this so many times from people
like i remember that from childhood or
yeah there was this time when you know
for a week i can feel it all the time
and
don't um
don't discount that don't discount your
intuition that that you have there's an
ability to live in peace to live in
intimacy spontaneity enjoyment of life
and orient to that give yourself
permission to orient to that even though
the social matrix does not value it the
social matrix values whatever it values
right it values relationships money
success fame health um
uh
competition like different things
this is none of those things and yet you
know it and if you know it if you can
feel it even the little part of your
being
orient to that and make it a priority
and you as christ said knock and it will
be opened period like it is is that
true that this has that kind of gravity
that you have
the birth is your birthright you have
the ability to wake up that's the number
one message ultimately probably number
two is and be willing to be
uncomfortable some of the time and you
won't be able to decide when that is
always
but some of some of this comes with
discomfort it's not all discomfort but
to to convince yourself it's supposed to
be all bliss supposed to be all whatever
you'll just be bypassing at some point
and and you you may miss some really
good opportunities
to
find what is what does it feel like what
does non-duality feel like in sadness
when there's no body there's no story
there's no gain or loss what is that
right here yeah
that opportunity is there for all of us
so
yeah i would say in that order those are
probably my top couple pieces of advice
and the third one would be something
like
don't take my descriptions
shanti's descriptions or muji's
descriptions or patanjali's descriptions
or
you know nagarjuna
don't take anyone else's descriptions
as more important or better than your
experience
not your opinions but your experience
your experience should should really be
primary all the time and these pointings
these videos these people the writings
the books all of it if you resonate
great awesome expose yourself to it
plenty
but
don't look at your own experience and go
well mine's probably wrong because
patanjali said this right don't do that
it's not
um
that's not the point of the pointing
by somebody who knows how to point or
who's really
genuinely trying to point you to your
true nature
um
trust
the immediate even if it's neutral even
if it feels contentless
you know don't look at it and go well
i'm supposed to feel bliss so something
must be wrong oh that's a thought oh
there's self-doubt in that oh okay
that's what i'm feeling right now and
all of a sudden presence right a deeper
uh uh experience of presence so trust
your trust your immediate experience
would probably be my third
i don't know guideline
cool
so
you can wake up
um trust your immediate experience
uh and what was the third again
well just be willing to be uncomfortable
at times well that's right we'll be
willing to see it as a school so
you can wake up
um
trust your immediate experience and be
willing to see it as a school
yeah
i love those
those are great ah these are so great
i mean next time we talk we i may have
different ones but that's what's coming
right now
yeah
i was thinking
about mesa
yeah i was also just really feeling
between us
i was feeling like
this first episode is a
just like a connection point between us
like
our first
but that um
every time i meet um
this sort of like awake vibrancy that
also knows how to like
shepherd itself that seeks like so all
of the other self that still seeks uh to
wake up
so
every time i feel this
radiance with another self like this
feels so good right now and
it only feels like uh the beginning of
something really beautiful together um
that can
be visited maybe every couple of months
like every quarter or something can um
revisit together and do a show and just
check in on how also like how we're
sharing our formation of like
the levels or the
um
and how we're communicating those uh
stages to the people that are asking um
so it it feels uh it feels great bro and
and i can tell like i can always tell
like it's a vibration it's a signature
um it's a presence and it and it feels
really good together
yeah i agree
at the beginning of the talk i'm i'm
always
with an interview especially someone i
don't know and so forth and more
importantly i don't know your audience
i'm always a little cautious of like how
direct to be because because this can
really freak people out like this can
really destabilize if i push people too
clearly
too directly
with certain kinds of pointings so um as
i was talking to you i can tell you you
totally get it energetically and stuff
and that's how i just assume your
audience is basically the same way so
um so i i'm more
apt to just talk however like when i
went on zubin show like i really thought
i had a z-dog md i had to sit him down
and be like you know
i didn't say that but i had to tell him
like
you might have people in your audience
like disappear after this they may not
enjoy it as much as you do it can be
really triggering to some people like i
always i always feel responsible for for
the message in a sense it's a wonderful
message but it's it's again it's
pointing to something that's a very very
powerful
potential
transformation in your life and if
you're not ready for it it's not
something you want to be pushed into so
when when i talked to him initially um i
i really was like okay we just gotta be
a little cautious how we introduce it
and he did something he had never done
before he did an introduction before our
talk to kind of give people a sense of
like if you're not interested in this
just tune out and watch my other stuff
you know uh because you know his
audience is is uh
varied quite varied you know a lot of
medical people and so forth but even
then
after those talks i've met so many
medical professionals and logical people
and scientific people who were totally
turned off by spirituality because they
thought it felt too woo-woo and so forth
but um
liked the directness and the the
simplicity i guess with which he and i
discussed it so every audience is a
little different i'm always a little you
know like
what do they really want to hear how
much do they want to hear how directly
do they want this but clearly you
uh you're good with it so
yeah well some of it um
i would say it's to an extent it's it's
twofold where
on one side it's
the interest of
um
like the channel itself like um
like i love the word channel because of
that um it's such a good word um and so
um the interest of this channel or this
expression of the one is
this and like then that's like that's
what it is that's what it came to it
came to
um exploring entrepreneur happiness then
exploring entrepreneurship then
exploring science and exploring
spirituality and then realizing oh i am
it oh this is what it is uh
and then
yeah and then you know so that that that
is now more and more so
the nature of the channel is to like
simplify what it is
to the rest of itself
and that's what is left um and there's
nothing more like exhilarating to do but
also to like build up the planetary
architectures that enable um basic needs
to be met decentralization to flourish
for everybody to actually be able to
like spend more time to actually inquire
into the nature of reality rather than
being so scattered and needing to um
invest all their time into accruing uh
dollars and basic needs to be met that
kind of thing so so there's a and that's
and that's the uniqueness of this
channel um and then people do tune in
sometimes people tune in more towards
some of the more science or business or
heavier stuff um and they tune some tune
really deeply into only this um like
entheogenic
um really just unleashing the diviner
god from within um more and more
um
and that's the same thing with you bro
is like you're in the same boat where
it doesn't really feel like you said you
have a job what is your job oh i'm an
anesthesiologist
an anesthesiologist
dude you've been putting people to sleep
your whole life i love it when people
would say that that's so funny
[Music]
another uh another person in no limits
society
nancy she also was an anesthesiologist
and so as she was as she was waking up
she's like i couldn't can't [ __ ]
believe that that um i've been putting
people asleep my whole life um it's just
a funny thing um yeah it is it is
i mean i've always been fascinated with
like consciousness i suppose
one way or another
you know maybe may have been that's an
unconscious decision for that reason but
yeah
um
for sure are you
also considering going full time into
this or how do you feel
um
you know i like the balance honestly i
like
medicine
i like
i like
interacting with people
um in in that way it's a it's a way to
serve for sure um so i don't really feel
moved to to
alter that necessarily because
i have plenty of time to like life is
fascinating it really is amazing what
it's done to like open up time for me to
do what i've been doing to write the
book to do
youtube videos i've been making a video
every day for a few months now just for
fun
um and i talk to a lot of people who are
going through your awakening process and
so forth so
not necessarily at this point um
uh things seem balanced they seem to i
don't i don't feel pushed for time
necessarily or like i can't do something
i want to do that or that i'm ready to
spend time doing uh it's more just
feeling into
when conditions feel right to i don't
know start the next book or whatever so
at this point things seem good
nice
um
i also just got a
an uh okay to check another area of uh
of the house or uh
well just
because i'm i know i'm just interested
in uh
and if it if it actually is the case
i can get a significantly better
um
internet connection in a different room
so
let's
let's see if that is the case
uh how how is it now let's see let's
just let's just
it's
similar i think
yeah a little
i can hear you okay i've not had a
problem with your sound
personally someone over here mentions
the sound issue earlier but i i haven't
had any problem with your sound
but your yeah your image just it just
freezes on occasion
and it's kind of pixelated sometimes but
not all the time it seems like an
intermittent thing visually
and let's see if the bars changed no it
actually hasn't
um so see here
maybe it is just better
are you on wi-fi are you on a wi-fi
connection or
oh it's back up to eight out of ten um
yeah i think i'll just i think i'll go
back yeah i am on a wi-fi but uh that's
another thing to
consider
okay i'm shifting back uh i think i'm
shifting back
so
all right
and then we'll wrap also we'll wrap here
shortly
we have uh
one of my uh one of my housemates said
that this property has um
steel in the walls that makes the
signal weaker
oh wow
which is which interesting yeah
um
so
so yeah we can just uh we can wrap in
this uh
and this is also good to know is that
when i'm when i'm traveling because
normally i've had a
for the last like
three
four almost years yeah almost four years
i've had a recording studio
in uh in san francisco and in l.a
and so
yeah so i've been in cali almost almost
10 years for almost a decade and i've
almost always had like a really awesome
internet connection and studio setup and
all this type of stuff
and now um i've sort of created more of
like a mobile unit for myself
um and that's a lot smaller and that
allows me to be a little more dramatic
and travel and so
now i'm working a team on the mission
which is just exciting global awakening
for this collective basically
um
yeah so now it's um
the internet connections are also
because we're sometimes we move and jump
around and so the internet connections
can fluctuate and so um that's another
thing to keep in mind is that if i do
these um remote ones
is we can also just do them and zoom and
record them and then upload them and
that might be
um save because that live component is
so nice and i love seeing people's live
comments i love bringing them in i love
the increase also in um the algorithm
for for being live and whatnot but in
the case of freezing video occasional
freezing audio and that kind of thing
it's not worth it because we want the
absolute highest quality of those two
things primarily um because we wanted to
be a good asset so i think moving
forward i'm just gonna um when i don't
have able internet connection i'm just
gonna record so even for our next
episode if i am in a place that does not
have a stable connection um we'll just
do it on zoom
okay fair enough
so yeah there was actually also a lot of
good um
commentary
like you were saying uh
it's like people enjoy enjoying the
episode it was good to hear from them
yeah good to hear from everybody
so
i also
just
tap for a
moment like
my
my uh my audio just became a little bit
more also choppy a second ago
let's see what's
the
okay
we'll uh
let me uh let me move over a little bit
and give myself some all this thing
let's see how is it right now looks good
right sounded good mm-hmm sound is good
video video is a little low-res it's
moving and looks fine
okay cool
um
i could also
i could also um see what the
how the internet is out here in the it
does it does i think it's going to be a
little bit better out here it's a little
bit uh
playing the internet game okay
sound is good
picture
frozen right now
it's [ __ ] weird
because
every every time it freezes it's like a
it's actually a really cool image it's
like
art
it's like maybe it's just my
interpretation
but sound is good
am i am i unfrozen
uh right now you're frozen
it's kind of a blurry image from when
you were moving through the hallway i
think
oh that's [ __ ] weird
oh so there's also probably a stability
to it like it likes to be in one
location there's probably also like a
little bit of
that going on
okay
let's uh let's go back to the rooms
let's see how it goes i also uh asked
some of the
uh the housemates about
just uh if they didn't need the internet
to disconnect for a little bit but
um
sweet i mean i'm feeling really good i'm
feeling really good about our first
convo and feeling really good about
um the way it went the way that we
clicked our energy our play together um
how we describe it i think how we
describe it is
like comes from many of the same like
ways of
secret paths and then bringing it all
together into
like one like one that can shape shift
across as needed and um
it was really fun it was so good it was
so good
and thanks all for
coming on uh an hour earlier given oh
welcome
what happened and uh i really appreciate
that flexibility and love and
um it worked out great because then we
got these photos 90 minutes um because
it was really nice
yeah my pleasure
so cool having you on so cool
oh also um for everybody thank you for
tuning in we love you guys
yeah thanks for coming yeah we would
love if you guys would
um subscribe to not only simulation our
channel also angelo's channel um you can
find that link in the bio below you can
like this video that helps the algorithm
you can comment below with your thoughts
on resonating in the episode we'd love
to hear from you
also you can check out angelo's website
as well that links in the bio below
simply alwaysawake.com check it out
um and he's got a bunch of stuff on
there including
videos um audio stuff um
some uh
uh i think even like some of the uh the
book is linked um most of the videos are
there
um
so you can find that there i also put
the the awake it's your turn the book
link in the
bio of the video also
um you can check that out
and
yeah go and support him and support him
more bring the love
yeah i wish everyone
i was just gonna say i wish everyone
watching fruition
peace
yes
so good thank you for that yeah 100
we wish you all fruition peace
love joy
prosperity abundance
playfulness
spontaneity
yeah freedom baby
[Laughter]
on a lived direct experience on a
non-conceptual level yeah it's so good
sweet i'll end the i'll end the call and
then you will not actually stay in the
uh studio for a minute and uh thanks
again
everyone much